If you can think of a way to construct gender, it exists. There are cultures
across the globe where there are three genders. In Thailand for example, there,
there are three genders. in, in certain Native American groups or indigenous
groups to the Americas, there are four genders. In parts of China there are
older communities that have five genders. and when we think about that from a
binary gender lands it's almost impossible to wrap our mind around it. until we
start to really realize, we think about our own gender and we think, oh gosh,
some days I feel very masculine. You know, maybe when I'm at work maybe I have
a job where I'm surrounded by a lot of men. Maybe I do construction yet I
happen to have a breast and, and vulva, but I don't really feel like a woman in
that context because I'm not really doing things that are very stereotypically
feminine. I kind of feel masculine. But then, then when I go home and I have my
male partner and I have children, I feel very feminine. I, I'm mothering. I
feel like a woman. And so when we start to think about gender as something that
is fluid throughout the day as something that varies from place to place on the
globe. And it's different across time. I mean, the concept of this gender
binary pink blue society that we have in the United States, for example, really
didn't really emerge until, you know, the 1900's that, that really is a new
concept. And really with the advent of this pink blue thing, that was like the
1950's. And so in asking what gender is really we need to ask ourselves what is
gender to me and what is gender to you and how is that similar and how is it
different. And we really should be mindful not to make assumptions, which is
why I really encourage like, the therapists I work with now, to ask people, you
know, how do you gender identify. Or I gender identify as, as a girl and as a
woman and please you the pronoun she and her. Because we can't make
assumptions. For example, some people might feel very androgynous. Where they
have a mixed feeling of being masculine and feminine. Maybe they prefer the
gender pronoun of they, and them. So we just can't know. and I think that's
exciting. I mean, I think the idea that gender can be and is constructed in
multitudes of ways that we can't even really grok is kind of amazing.